[Music]
a place like mit is very hard to get
through on your own
and you really need that sense of
community and that sense of support
around you to make it
my biggest support system were the
people around me
and i want to make sure that other
people have access to those same
resources of the same people and have
spaces
to work on those relationships and again
network with different people to get
that support that they need
she's a very empathetic person and she's
a great listener i've seen her in
different focus groups and various
conversations
quietly sitting back and listening to
people
and letting people have their time and
their space to be able to say and talk
about very difficult topics
i take a lot of energy from the people
around me and the community that i have
and i have a lot of love for that
community
yes there's work that needs to be done
but at the end of the day i will read
the benefits of having a better
department to be a part of
congratulations to lena for this
recognition
and i would say to the broader world you
are so fortunate that you will be
getting from us
a graduate who was really well poised to
take her skills and her wonderful
personality and her commitment to being
a positive force uh into the broader
community so for those outside of mit
get ready you're getting one of our best
and we really are excited to see what
lena does when she leaves here and i'm
looking forward to hearing more about
her in the future
i'm hopefully graduating in the spring
and i know a lot of companies have
professional affinity groups so that's
something that i look for
in
companies when i interview with them
because i want to be in a space that
also
has groups like nobushi or like black
affinity groups or women infinity groups
or muslim affinity groups stuff like
that because i want to know that a
company values diversity equity and
inclusion
you